[Music]
foreign could somebody scale a building
and infiltrate using you know a laser
cutting glass thing yes it could be done
but no poll would do that in broad
daylight my name is Andrew Bustamante
and I am a former covert CIA
intelligence officer I served with CIA
for seven years in the National
Clandestine Service and now I'm the
founder of everyday spy where I teach
spy skills to Everyday People today
we're going to be looking at the Mission
Impossible movies and determining just
how real they are
so this I think is very apropos for the
time because this was how we used to
protect information they're downloading
this NOC list the knock list it stands
for non-official cover meaning this is a
list of assets and agents around the
world that are not protected by any kind
of government cover backstopping you
would have it on a standalone server in
a standalone computer
foreign
so they both have matching gloves on and
that's that's not how it works in the
real world in the real world each
individual part of a team has a
completely different set of Kit if
they're captured separate from the
operation you don't want them to have
matching kit otherwise that gives the
police or the local law enforcement a
chance to tie the two together also
you'll see that Ethan is wearing a pair
of glasses and they're just normal
glasses that hook over his ears in the
real world when you're on any kind of
field operation you don't leave anything
to chance his lenses would be custom
made to fit his eyes but then they'd be
actually strapped close around his face
when it comes to this specific activity
where Ethan is being lowered into a room
from above we do learn how to belay each
other we do learn how to work as
counterbalances and how to use some of
these rope and pulley systems in
different types of Arenas the other
thing that you see Happening Here is
that there's multiple people who are
supporting Ethan you've got one person
who's supporting him in the tech van and
then you have another person who's
actually belaying him from above now
support elements are very realistic in
spy operations you take away some of the
little silly nuances I mean this is a
pretty solidly realistic representation
of what a field officer's capabilities
are I would really give this about a
seven on a scale of 10.
foreign
rock climbing is 100 a thing that CIA
officers get into because being alone is
Where We Gather our energy we clear our
minds we get creative we might find
ourselves in a position where we would
have to do this to escape out of a
dangerous scenario so for those reasons
we do have advanced schools to teach our
officers how to do some pretty amazing
things
even Ethan Chuckles a bit look at that
so first keep in mind that in the
Mission Impossible movies Ethan Hunt
works for an organization called IMF the
impossible mission force and the IMF is
actually a contractor underneath the CIA
if he was a full-fledged CIA officer he
would not get a secret briefing or a
classified briefing anywhere except
inside of a facility that houses what's
known as a skiff secure compartmented
information facility and most certainly
not delivered through a shoulder-held
rocket from some strange guy in a
helicopter that is in our terminology
called a live drop you may select any
two team member but it is essential that
the third team member the Naya
nordorfall
the fact that he's being given a team
that is very real also the fact that
part of his team includes a professional
Thief not a professional intelligence
officer that is also fairly accurate we
oftentimes work with convicted felons
because felons and spies really aren't
that different the difference is a spy
is trained and given cover and authority
to break laws where a thief learns
through the School of Hard Knocks
self-destruct in five seconds nobody can
think of Mission Impossible without also
thinking of that line that says this
message will self-destruct now in real
life nothing self-destructs because
there has to be what's known as an audit
Trail in order for the government to be
able to demonstrate that they're
spending those tax dollars in a
judicious and legitimate way I would
give this about a seven in terms of
accuracy for how a true field operations
officer will go through essentially
resetting themselves before taking a new
mission
spy cameras are something that has been
well known about Espionage for a long
time but what people don't understand is
that the value of a spy camera isn't
necessarily in how it's concealed as
much as it's about the power and
accuracy of the camera itself the fact
that in this clip we're seeing a hidden
camera inside of a beauty mirror but
when you actually see the quality of the
camera image it's relatively low that's
actually the opposite of what I would
expect to see in the real world so
instead what you would most likely see
is a very high quality camera inside
something heavier
[Music]
yeah
oh my gosh we all joined CIA so that we
can do what Ethan Hunt does let's be
honest it is true that a prosthetic can
be created from 3D modeling but it's not
really true that that 3D modeling is
going to come through some sort of
custom-built piece of photographic
equipment like the powder kit that the
agent was using in this you need to have
all of the right angles and all of the
right depth of field from each of those
angles so that you can create a proper
model
foreign
that's called a principle or the
impersonation of a principle which is
dangerous for lots of reasons voice
Behavior tonality we don't ever
impersonate a principle what we try to
do is we try to impersonate someone
who's within the circle of trust of a
principle that way the only person that
we're really trying to trick is the
principle themselves having a full-faced
prosthetic to be that principle the risk
is just compounded I'm gonna have to
give this one about a three out of 10
for accuracy
don't do this just let it go I mean
everything in this clip is wrong
according to CIA training during this
entire negotiation Ethan is pleading
which reinforces that the principle is
the one in control control is an
incredibly important thing in an
intelligence operation you always want
to be the one in control this is called
a hostile negotiation we're actually
given a very specific script we'll
repeat our name we'll repeat our social
security number we'll repeat our cover
we'll repeat whatever core truths are
relevant to us in that operation which
is actually what happens when you
threaten somebody they really do
oftentimes fall to this base level
repetition I didn't do it I didn't do it
I didn't do it I didn't do it so we're
trained to mimic that repeating pattern
so that it protects us from giving away
information none of that is being used
here by Ethan in this example the only
way you're gonna get what you want is
for you
the trick to any negotiation you always
want to cause as much stress as possible
to the other person because the person
under stress is going to make poor
strategic decisions through the process
of that negotiation and unfortunately as
I watch this clip I'm rooting for the
bad guy because he's the one doing this
right it's not what I would expect from
a trained intelligence operative but in
terms of reality I mean I'm going to
give this an eight in terms of what a
true hostile negotiation between violent
people would look like
[Music]
I really like the disguise in this much
better than some of the other disguise
work that we've seen a simple prosthetic
nose and mustache piece is exactly what
we would use and prefer to use because
it reduces the amount of what can go
wrong unlike a full head prosthetic he
doesn't speak which is very wise that is
actually very accurate when you're
wearing Prosthetics or when you're
trying to appear as somebody with an
advanced disguise you're not going to
speak because there's no reason to add
that extra layer of potential risk into
your operation
foreign
that kind of tech is extremely difficult
to make it's just not realistic the cost
the time the risk is all too great to
create Tech like that and then
surprisingly the thing that holds most
tech back in the field is actually just
the availability of battery power the
larger a piece of tech is the more
battery it requires so as nicely as it
is to to fold the whole thing up into a
briefcase the battery that would be
required to run that thing would be a
second like Wheeling suitcase
now what you see Ethan do is he goes
from his disguise he rips away parts of
his disguise and essentially now he
looks like a tourist instead of looking
like a Russian general that technique is
called a gap act now the difference
between how Ethan did it and how we do
it in the field is Ethan did it in like
Plain Sight that's a very high risk
place to transform in the real world you
would find a place where you have 15 to
30 seconds with nobody observing you at
all you wouldn't just discard your hat
and fake nose on the corner like you saw
him do he just ripped it off and threw
it off to the side because that leaves
evidence instead your kit would include
everything is reversible including a
reversible bag so that you leave no
Trace behind that you ever changed in
the first place
[Music]
episode 20 Vision A2 Delta Echo
requesting immediate Evac
a lot of really interesting stuff he
picks up that phone and he calls a
number that that number is what's known
as a backstop number when you hear the
phone pick up and say such and such
insurance company that is also what's
known as a verbal parole that's how
Ethan knows he's talking to the right
phone number he gives his paroles or
what's known as Bona fides that makes
sure that the person on the other line
knows that they're talking to the right
person and then he disposes of the phone
here in this little sewer great where
nobody can retrieve it the verbal
paroles The Bona fides and the disposal
is all very accurate the first half of
the clip with all the tech and the
disguise stuff up front I would give
that more like a 3 out of 10 in terms of
reality but the back end of the clip
that's a much more realistic clip I
would give that closer to a six or a
seven in terms of reality
fifty percent of his Tech fails him and
he still has to figure it out anyways
that is so awesomely real now when he
takes the glove off and he throws it
over his shoulder again we've talked
about this Tom we don't discard our
equipment in the field because it leaves
a trail of evidence when the tech fails
what he would really do is he would
stash it away in his belt
[Music]
could somebody scale a building and
infiltrate using you know a laser
cutting glass thing yes it could be done
but no pole would do that in broad
daylight a spy's best friend is the
concealment of Night and the fact that
he's executing this operation in broad
daylight in the United Arab Emirates
it's just not accurate it's really
important to understand that all of
Espionage is illegal what happens is
your government sanctions you to carry
out illegal acts Ethan could very much
be prosecuted by an emirati judge or any
neighboring Allied country if they were
to capture him engaging in the act of
Espionage on behalf of the United States
what you see Ethan doing here is he's
breaking into a server room most likely
because he's sabotaging the server
itself now this is an example of what we
call a human enabled technical operation
so here Ethan is using human skills to
enable a technical operation that
otherwise would have been much harder or
potentially not feasible at all without
a human element so I'm going to give
this about its 5 out of 10 for accuracy
overall
oh action sequence here okay one of the
things I love the most about car scenes
is having been trained in how to
actually tactically and offensively
drive a car we're taught at the agency
to use our vehicle as a weapon as much
as we use it as a defensive tool
whenever it comes to any kind of vehicle
you're never using the front of the
vehicle when Ethan runs over the
motorcycle directly in front of him a
real Combat driver would have moved to
one side of the alley or the other in
the hopes that they'd be able to Nick or
push the rear tire of the motorcycle out
of position so the motorcycle would
tumble without blocking the car itself
there are a number of not natural
vehicle movements handbrake turns are
real and handbrake turns are very useful
things however to do a handbrake turn
you need to be moving on gravel terrain
or on terrain that is loose or with bald
tires you have to loosen the whole car's
grip with the ground not only that but
you need to actually have compression on
one side of the car or the other so that
you would actually get the spinning
motion that you see them have there
[Music]
driving in Reverse is a super powerful
way to drive because it protects your
front engine and it turns all the space
behind you into essentially weaponized
space however there's only one gear when
you drive in Reverse so you really max
out at about 25 miles an hour
[Music]
hang on
so you see them collapse on their trunk
and that's when their airbags deploy
which isn't how it would work there are
high speed chases in foreign operations
overseas in reality they would have been
driving much much slower than that high
speed is really more like 25 to 30 miles
an hour vehicles around the world are
basically built so that those front
airbags will deploy when there's a
collision between 12 and 25 miles an
hour so when they rear-end that
motorcycle that would have been the end
of the scene because the airbags would
have deployed that was not very accurate
so I would give that probably like a a
two or a three out of 10. foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this is out there oh my gosh could an
assassination be scheduled in an opera
absolutely it wouldn't be the way that
it's portrayed in this scene you've got
this weird sort of triangle of Shooters
so you generally don't try to get
multiple weapons smuggled into an
access-controlled area because if one of
them is captured then the security is is
increased for all the others usually you
would just try to have one person in
there or even better you would pre-place
one weapon and have one person be in
charge of capturing or liberating that
pre-placed weapon
[Music]
the fact that each of these weapons was
individually crafted to look like
something else that is completely
unrealistic when you create a weapon
especially a high accuracy weapon even
just aligning your targeting elements
with the actual barrel of the weapon is
extremely difficult so for that reason
we would prefer to actually smuggle in a
fully functional weapon I would also say
that you know CIA experimented with
these weapons back in the 60s the 50s
the Cold War era umbrellas that have
been fabricated to fire bullets pens
lipsticks that's supposed to be carried
out in a natural course right like an
umbrella is something you would
naturally point on the way to you know
deploy it or open it
foreign
you can see that they're trying to cover
some of the noise that's coming from
these suppressed rifles now it is
possible to suppress rifles up to a
certain caliber but then there becomes
such a high caliber that it just isn't
feasible to suppress it there's an
incredible amount of complexity here
that is well outside of the norm this is
probably the worst performing of all the
clips that we've seen so far I'm going
to give this one a generous one out of
ten
iocia an eternal debt of gratitude for
teaching me how much it honestly
hurts to get punched in a vulnerable
spot we're trained in them and not even
in mixed martial arts we're really
trained in a very simple kinetic
fighting system that's designed so that
we don't get captured so one of the
things I really enjoyed about this scene
is that they highlighted those
vulnerable spots we saw a throat punch
we saw using a briefcase to hit somebody
across the temple we saw solar plexus
punches we saw solar plexus kicks now
some of the places where it didn't
really work how quickly people recovered
it really only takes one or two key
strikes before you are done
the other thing I didn't really like was
uh both Ethan and his his co-fighter
were taking turns were specifically
trained not to take turns when you're
two on one an opponent uh that's
something that happens in the movies you
both attack at the same time to
overwhelm your opponent
Ethan just grabs the guy and runs him
into a wall there's the struggle over
the handgun at the end and there's this
resisting we're taught that whenever
there's a moment of resistance like that
you change tactics right you steer the
muzzle away from yourself you use that
as a chance to break out of those locked
moments so that you can get back to a
place of tactical dominance I would give
this probably a 4 out of 10 for reality
this is an interesting scene if Ethan is
undercover and the police officer is not
associated with his cover operation he's
not going to save her when you're
undercover your mission takes priority
over everything
so there's a couple things here when the
scene first starts how many weapons are
pointed at Ethan none of them he would
do a quick draw and then he would
actually go in order of the other drawn
weapons so he would shoot the gentleman
close to him he would shoot the guy on
the right the guy on the left and then
the guy with his uh hand on his
waistband last not only that but when
Ethan actually attacks he does one
majorly wrong thing because he continues
to fire one two three all without moving
movement is the first thing that we're
taught in any kind of counter-attack
situation so Ethan would have actually
moved more like four to five feet so he
would have shot shot again continued to
move shot again shot again so the fact
that Ethan waited so long to shoot and
then shot all four folks from the same
essentially one foot area
kind of shows how this was made for a
camera and not made for reality a really
solid seven in terms of reality
and this is why nobody talks about
Mission Impossible you know Tom Cruise
did that stunt and he didn't just do it
once he did it multiple times to get
everything right CIA teaches us how to
ride a number of different types of
vehicles right from four-wheel Vehicles
two-wheel Vehicles motorized vehicles
and the idea that you know you would
drive a perfectly good motorcycle off a
cliff that's not something we're trained
to do and then to be able to deploy a
parachute and essentially base jump
from a motorcycle the battery is just
thick and it's awesome I would give this
a 10. that is a real man riding a real
motorcycle off of a real ramp into
into the air in the real world there is
no Ethan Hunt for the most part a lucky
CIA career will have one moment of
excitement that even comes close to what
Ethan does one explosion one high-speed
car chase one border crossing where your
disguise Works my favorite spy show is
actually season one of the Americans
because season one of the Americans was
really an excellent example of what true
Espionage looks like they kind of built
that foundation around real tradecraft
real relationships Deep Cover if you
enjoyed this video make sure you click
on the link above to get the next